bismillah al hamdulillah
welcome to the Deen show peace be with
you I may be your host I thank you for
tuning in we have back in the Dean shell
studio with us sheikh Kareem and we're
gonna be answering some of your
questions here on the Deen show we'll be
right back Salam alaikum our you could
sell out of the library
how are you [ __ ] alhamdulillah all
praise be to Allah so final time you
know many people that are out there
tuning they want to know because it's
all over the news you know Islam Muslims
and a lot of false things being
attributed to Islam so they heard an
Arabic word Allah can you go ahead and
define you know what Allah means because
some people think that this is some
foreign god that the muslims worship
who's allah well let me start with by
saying that we have Arab Christians and
Arab Jews and we have the Old Testament
and the New Testament in Arabic you know
that right the viewers know that guess
what in the first page in the book of
Genesis the Old Testament in the Arabic
version Allah was used 17 times 17 times
Allah Allah this is how we refer to it
kills that argument yes weak yeah
without even having to go over Suzanne
who speak Arabic read Arabic yeah Allah
is used alas use there you know who
Allah is not not nothing not Jesus
now do you hope not but Allah know
that's it and it's in the place of God
with a capital G not with a small G with
a capital G yeah yeah wow that's amazing
I mean you you also I'm you you do some
I've seen some of your
debates dialogues with people of
different religions as Christians so I'm
sure you're also well-versed as a
comparative student also of different
religions a little bit right
I strive we strive to learn because you
know we want the knowledge
have you seen anywhere else that because
you know to find the truth some people
make it seem like it's so difficult like
all these religions are making the claim
but have you ever just with this one
point seen anywhere in the Bible or any
Hindu screw any where that the creator
is making himself known so clearly
saying like we have in the Quran where
Allah say I am your Creator
I'm Allah I created you this universe
and everything in it it's crystal clear
do you see anything like that absolutely
I mean there are some if you approach
any scriptural text with any
preconceived notions
you could always manipulate the text but
listen talking about people being God or
attributing divinity to people that's
how we like to vote a bullet for example
Jesus Alice and a peace be upon him The
Messenger of Allah listen Jesus was born
this is just one fact Allah has no
beginning who ll work he is the first
LASIK habla Jose none existed before him
and amazing subhanAllah this is the
first paragraph in the book of Genesis
in the beginning it was God
they begin when you say that somebody is
born for example like Jesus or any other
human being or Jose that means he has a
birthday that's why when I speak to
Christians I tell them God doesn't have
a birthday that's real deep right yes
just think about it it doesn't have a
birthday another one right away is the
fact that and this is this argument was
actually addressed in the Quran look at
this
many mercy hugged no Maruyama allah
rasool infertility mean public opposed
Lumos of the haqqani apart look look the
messenger that Messiah the Messiah is
Jesus peace be upon him King is a
messenger came in a chain of my
after Mussolini and his mother is a
truthful woman look at this they used to
eat food for them to survive this is in
the Koran now in the Quran you need food
yes
that means they need to sleep that means
they need they do need God is free of me
go to the bathroom now that's really
deep if you think about it yeah I mean
this is but Allah clear I'm free of lead
yeah they needed to sleep they needed to
sleep Allah doesn't sleep Allahu Allah
Allahu al haaj you let who do who sinner
- no no no yeah there is an author
Swahili and one of the Israelites which
we do not believe we do not go lie there
are things that we get from the people
of the book from the Christian and the
Jews who accepted Islam and they bring
some of the teachings into Islam as long
as it's not contradictory to our
teachings we do not believe it we do not
be lied and we couldn't read it that
prophet musa alayhis salam asked allah
subhana wa ta'ala this question how come
oh Allah you do not sleep so Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala wanted him to
experience something they said he stand
up and he had him hold an object in his
hand stand up until I tell you to sit up
and hold this yeah yes you know you
could try this at home right now right
yeah he can try this right now a slumber
of asleep overtake overtook him so he's
standing up yes
holding holding something a cup a cup in
his hand even a cup that weighs three
ounces try it even the lightest even the
lightest a slumber of asleep overtook
him what happened to the object he said
by my might by my glory if a slumber of
asleep would overtake me the heavens
would crumble on earth and this is in
the Quran in Allah whom seekest Sumati
well are the antigen volume sukhasana
and Taha I love the iliad knee and he is
holding the heavens not to fall down on
earth the Creator the Creator except
with his permission which is in the
flesh you can say that God created the
heavens and earth
and in six day and then rested on the
service that goes back what you're
saying you see Eddie Eddie we are I
think this is what draws the line
between us and Christian and Jews
you see Christians Jews Muslims they
speak of a god but we differ on the
concept whose the concept you see for me
as a Muslim to say Allah arrested huh
number one in the viewers we need to
know that in surah kahf Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala dismissed this totally and he
actually said do not say that while al
Qaeda holic now look at the verse in
surah kahf y Lapid jalapenos Emirati
well although another in a whom f is it
that he I am in one honest enemy loop
indeed I have created we have created
the heavens and the earth in six days
and what's in between them in six days
and no fatigue touched yeah that's the
word mass Sena the the beginning of
fatigue now if we say Allah rested that
means you're saying Allah gets tired be
careful
we as Muslims we do not use these terms
with Allah subhana WA Ta'ala were very
disciplined even when we negate things
regarding Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
we only negate that which Allah negated
I cannot say for example as a Muslim
Allah doesn't walk in the street well I
had to Belen and I'm just doing this for
Allah forgive me and I'm just doing this
for the sake of Education I cannot say
Allah doesn't go to the demo I cannot
say that I only say negative I say Allah
is not blind
one-eyed I mean why is not one-eyed
innallaha is happy hour because it was
established so I negate and affirm their
names and the attributes which are
negated and affirmed in the revelation
were very disciplined once we talk about
a loss of Hanna that and that's what
draws the line between us and so nothing
is said about the creator that he didn't
say about himself so you can't make up
things according to your fancies because
logically I haven't seen him have you
seen him subhanaw taala
no no one no one can so how in the world
do you speak what are you here to never
say in me he'll be Masha how in the
world you see there are two elements
here element number one that you have
not seen Allah and no one can so how in
the world can you
describe someone who you have not seen
okay number two there is none like him
so that you can use as a major yeah
there is none like him in the world his
he's not like his creations his
creations are not like him so you cannot
say okay I'm gonna describe that
creation because it looks like Allah so
those two elements out there so you have
to stick to what to what is what is bi
not look look so you're sure that no
one's seen God no one can no one can see
God are you sure absolutely
okay you heard what he said because
there's some people saying it it's all
got this and we're gonna be right back
to this question to ask this question
about have you really seen God some
people say they have we'll be right back
here on Adi show I want you to imagine
you wake up and in front of you or a
bunch of guys running around kicking a
ball no goals no lines no rules what
would you think but is that your life
surely every sport has its goal every
game has its end it has its objective it
has its rules how about life how about
our life isn't there a goal to life
isn't there a purpose an objective that
we have to reach we think so the Quran
tells us that we exist in order to
worship God and worshiping God means
knowing God as the Quran says when the
holocrons in the will insert allure Leah
badoon worship though is not some narrow
small thing its wide its vast it
encompasses everything that the human
being does everything that you do
everything that you think everything
that you feel can be done thought said
felt in a way that is either pleasing or
displeasing to God the purpose of life
is to try and do everything in a way
that God loves and God is pleased with
that is your goal back here on the Deen
show and we're a time
very important issue that you know
talking about the creator without
knowledge is something that we don't do
so we have the RO Batum Word of God God
Almighty sent revelation throughout time
and the last final revelation is the
Quran previous revelations were sent we
believe in the original Torah the
original injeel gospel that was given to
jesus peace be upon him what was given
to David of the Psalms but these
scriptures over time they got corrupted
changed so God sent the last the final
revelation the Quran so when we get to
talking to people you know when we do
then we give the invitation Islam is
based on proof and evidences and we talk
to people and we explained to them that
Jesus he never claimed divinity nor did
he talk Trinity or calling people to
worship himself alongside with God and
then it goes back and forth and some
people will say and this goes back to
what you were saying they say look God
spoke to me he spoke to my heart I saw
him in a dream so you said that no one
saw God but they said those people and
I've talked to him myself personally
gonna answer this in a very interesting
way go ahead
you know we believe that there is a
character who emerged
right before the second coming of a
solid salaam prophet Jesus which is the
Antichrist the Antichrist his initial
emerging emergence into an emerging into
earth he will claim to be a prophet and
then finally he will say I am God now
you know the prophet sallallaahu are you
sellin me that very interesting comment
when you say prophet sallallaahu labor
solemn he's be upon him now you talk
about the last a phenomenal promo yes
okay yes when the prophet Solomon was
talking to his companions warning them
about the Antichrist he made that
statement you know what he said alamou
and now come Lanter Inara become hotter
thammudu the hadith and I am a Muslim
rest assure that you will never be able
to see Allah unless you die or until you
die so look at this now the fact look at
this now Eddie the fact that the
Antichrist is saying he's Allah and
you're still in this world this is the
first argument or the first point that
that that dismisses the fact that he's
got that I'm able to see you the fact
I'm able to see you and you're supposed
to be God because I'm not supposed to
see you in this world after this is the
defect in his face you're the creator
and you made me with two eyes and you
only have one eye go fix your eye man I
mean come on you made me better than you
so the creation is better than the
Creator after this we have a very
interesting experiment which prophet
Musa al-salaam went through and it was
recorded in surah al-araf or ad namu
settle Athena relative Mohave Ashley I'm
Fatima MacArthur Robbie or Benelli the
meaning of Musa al-salaam would allah
subhanallah the children of israel by
the way the Jews during the time because
they lived in Egypt so many times and
the Egyptians used to worship idols they
got contaminated by this that you need
to see God so they kept asking moosa
aleihsalaam
we will not believe unless we are led
not mean a like a hotter neurologic I'm
saying Moses yeah - to Moses Ali said
I'm that we will not believe what you're
conveying unless we see Allah like so
prophet was irony in a way when Allah
was speaking to him Colorado well
imagine a Mussolini cut in a corner of
be a Dini under a lake
oh Allah can you make me see you Carolyn
Perron E you're not going to be able to
because the way that were fashioned ad
that our body cannot handle it the
greatness of allah subhanaw taala cannot
be absorbed in no no no there is a veil
between us and Allah if Allah and
removes that but that veil does not
prevent him from seeing and hearing us
be careful Haditha be musa al-ashari and
the Muslim in Allah Helena while I am
very la who and Jana Allah does not
sleep and his sleep and it's not
befitting for him to sleep
Yahoo focused over foul he lowers people
who put down people you're far away I'm
a black male in her hour these are
presented to him at night before the day
and the day before the night hey
Jeroboam who know there is a veil
between him and his creation
Lokesh aha who if that veil is removed
everything will burn everything will
burn so imagine this but again be
careful that veil does not prevent a
from healing and seeing what do you tell
someone now let's say our brothers in
humanity the Christian quickly and in a
minute or so a lhasa tomb you're not
gonna be able to learn Taurani but
listen if you wanna try this let's do it
well a penumbral elgible who the
mountain is if you went to Sinai of into
Sinai the mountains there are out of
this world I mean huge mountains Rossi
you look at this mountain I'm gonna
descend on this mountain of course we
believe that a lot of the sentence and a
phase in a way that fits His Majesty we
do not reject the attribute of
descending like people do but we do not
try to lighten it for our descending no
we try to visualize it or figure out how
he descends later commit Lachey
it's a chemically Shay and at the end of
the world Leia
11k if Allah Allah the only one who
knows how Allah is Allah subhanAllah
no one is like Allah subhanAllah nothing
resembles nothing resembles him no rival
resembles him no one is like him and and
so so we believe that Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala he descends in a certain way how
he the sense I don't know but I believe
he descends should I strive to know no
you should not but you must believe that
he descends so allah subhanaw taala
descended on the top of this mountain
this what happened to the mountain what
would you say to our brothers in
humanity who say the christians many are
many others who say look that jesus came
to me in a dream God came to me in a
dream and told me to do things this way
what do you say you know those who Eddie
who say that we we see in Allah we seen
the messenger I don't want to get into
whether they saw or not that's whether
they even believe or not whether they
had will do or not whether they pray
five times or not we could go attack the
issue tackle the issue from there but
let's say that that you see in a dream
our messengers told us and had a sorry
film film Okkadu o Muslim that a dream
belongs to one of the following three
categories whether it is hadith enough
something that you consumed with your
thinking all the day about
you know ice cream it's just you're
consumed with it you could see ice cream
in your dream at night hadith because
something is something that you're
thinking about all the time your nafs is
is attached to all the time then you
dream of it at night
number two is from Shaitaan that
Shaitaan comes and the devil the devil
yes Satan and a comes actually and
reveals things do to scare you
number three is from Allah Yanni it
could be from Allah subhanAllah but
let's say that you saw in your dream
that someone telling you Eddie you don't
have to pray anymore you're good
let's say that and you're certain is
from Allah can you implement that dream
no you clap salutely not you have to
take this to the Sharia if you see a
dream get a kill your your your neighbor
you go on and kill it and say it's no
worry for we'll disciplined Eddie we go
through the Sharia that that really go
through the D so the revelation says
opposite now you can't go ahead and do
our opposite to the revelation whatever
you see in your dreams has to be
measured by the religion yeah but it
does not override the religion you see
that's a sect in Islam
that that gone astray in that field they
say hadith and it'll be on Rabi that I
received my religion Street between me
and Allah my heart is connected with
Allah I don't have to go through
messengers and this is where I said at
the beginning that if you actually
reject the message and the messenger
ship you go out of the fold of Islam you
believe that you connect directly with
allah subhanaw taala without a medium
without the messenger the way to Allah
is the way of the messenger and you
heard that you can't reject any of the
messengers you can't reject Jesus Moses
Abraham or the last in front of
messengers sent to all of mankind upon
Muhammad peace be upon him who call
people to worship the Creator not his
creation we'd right back with more here
in the D show
back here on the Dean show with Shaykh
Kareem tell us sheikh we're talking
about we're talking about the dreams and
some people will say they had this
experience have you had any experience
because you host the TV show called
let's talk about it have any non not yet
Muslims called in or people and they
actually as soon as they say dreams I
say I don't interpret the dreams they
ask you about interpreting dreams I
don't I tell them right away with some
colors they call [ __ ] I saw night it
right away I actually got to be a
specialist in that area or how is they
know is not that you know I'm not I'm
I'm a guy who you know who tells the
religious rulings based on the text I'm
not there to say your dreams mean that
or mean that in my opinion and my humble
opinion actually yeah you're right you
must have the skill of doing it this is
number one but you should not do this in
initial because a lot of people make a
lot out of these dreams and they have to
be extremely careful
I mean dreams in a way are a form of
revelation from Allah revelation in the
sense not literally but allah subhanaw
taala is conveying a message to you in a
way but we should not we always have to
take it to the religion we have to take
it to the dean so i don't try to present
myself to be that because people
sometimes make a big deal out of those
people how we see that you know just
from studying this way of life islam
it's the natural way it calls you not to
do anything that's weird out of this
world it's really straightforward and
simple worshiping the creator and not
his creation establishing the prayer
five times a day now because you know
some people say well well why do I have
to pray you know what does God need my
prayer you know that's that's something
else that some excuse some people what
would would make like what's the point
of prayer but we know that okay as
Muslims we have to pray that's for us to
develop ourselves more God consciousness
keeps us away from evil he's right now
this building so how could someone be
certain now that look they come from a
way of life that everything's confusing
it's kind of makeup things as you go
everyone
their own opinion you find ten people in
a room with 12 13 different opinions
when you come over to Islam it's
straight cut it's really simple
understand so what's the first step now
what's the first step than somebody
who's look they really you know our
searching but they're coming from a land
of confusion now you know you just throw
in Islam in the buffet just another
religion how do you I like I like what
you said you know I heard you I don't
know more than one time I love that line
that always seek guidance from him go
down the ground and prostrate because if
Allah guides you no one can take you
astray even if the whole world gather
that's simple simple so that's it starts
out right now right now right now you
know you just now have you know have no
reservations in your heart whatever we
you show to me oh Allah I will follow it
this is the first commitment that you
should make whatever whatever way even
if it is the way of the Muslims I will
follow it make that vow make that
commitment and beg him every day every
night go down like Jesus peace be upon
him is a leash and I'm dead on your
forehead and ask you cannot imagine any
a lot of people who accepted Islam they
told me they done this they told me they
run this at night they would be crying
and weeping and they are so that
stressed depressed they are about to
kill themselves and they break and tears
and when you're at that stage you really
feel that connection between you and
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala their forehead
and they they they prostrate and then a
quest guide me I want you I wanna that's
what you need to do that's the first
initial step the first initial then
after that if it is the way of Islam
which it is no question about it
then begin learning a crap read but
begin learning la ilaha ilallah pure
monotheism no Allah is that is the first
requirement that you need to know don't
get indulged in all these details of the
religion you're going to be distract
get to know your Lord get to know who
Allah is and this is what the messenger
did with his Harbor for 13 years as a
share of the aluminum aluminum narrates
that all what in one rule from the Quran
is who Allah is Jenna and hell 13 years
that's what you need to learn but of
course they still have to pray and I'm
not saying that they they're gonna put
Salah aside that now that's not what I'm
saying but knowledge should be focused
here
no no Allah is know the basics how to
pray al-fatiha
Jonnie Jonnie the Salah and so forth now
from the carry on and take it easy you
see a big obstacle in the faces of those
who accept Islam that they look at the
package in its totality and they think
they cannot do it and that's why I found
plays in them are you gonna do all of
this this is not gonna work you see what
Allah subhana WA Ta'ala wants from you
is to believe in him and make a full
commitment in your heart that you will
submit to him no reserve ish and then
factor Kula Hamas Novato strive strive
if you fall short oh Allah forgive me I
can do this or Allah help me to do this
if you fall into a sin or Allah forgive
me out and work they'll build that's how
it goes
make strives each and every day you
don't give us a roadmap robot map slams
that road map yes and at the end Jinnah
that's a paradise today thank you very
much we're out of time thank you very
much again let me the creator of the
heavens in her for-ward you say thank
you and that's the first simple step
that you can start with because if
you're on xanax if you're on
antidepressants and if you're looking
for love in all the wrong places with
that beer bottle you know that
something's missing
so start break down shed one tear or
many if you have to but ask the Creator
earnestly to guide you humble yourself
because death is a reality and when it
approaches it's too late and then all
that stuff has been numbing your mind
all that music and entertainment that
takes you away from reality but when
death comes then you're in the reality
and then it's too late
Hellfire or paradise and did you work
hard
paradise you worked hard for that
paycheck you didn't get it for free so
paradise is not for free
you've got to strive in this life to be
the best that you can be and you need
the blueprint you need the game plan and
you got to get it from the one who
created mankind that's the one God so I
start to ask him do that simple that's
the homework right now start to ask the
Creator your maker my maker the one who
made everything in his universe for
guidance and give us a call 1 800 662
help piece be with you